why
so before we get into X Factor in Marvel
Comics we need to take a step back and
we need to talk about uncanny x-men
issues number 200 and 201 and the reason
why is because these comics are going to
give us the early formations of the
reasoning behind why X Factor was
created in the first place as to why it
is that the group came into existence
and as a brief synopsis what we saw with
issue number 200 was the trial of
Magneto and this is where magneto had
submitted himself to the authorities to
stand for his crimes against humanity
and this was simply just part of Magneto
turning over a new leaf of becoming a
reformed person but over the course of
this comic what we saw that magneto was
exonerated of his charges we also saw
that Professor Xavier began as to
succumb to some sort of illness now for
the most part the illness was of such a
degree to where it seemed as though it
would have killed him and so what we see
is that corsair and lilandra of the
Shiar Empire meet with Charles Xavier to
take him back to to the Shiar Empire for
medical treatment but we don't know
exactly how long Xavier is going to be
gone or if he's even going to come back
at all and so what Xavier does is he
appoints magneto to be the head of the
Xavier Institute and instead now magneto
was a little reluctant to this at first
and the reason why is because he's been
a foe of the x-men for almost their
entire existence and so he thinks that
the x-men will almost immediately rebuke
him and will refuse to stand by him but
what Charles Xavier says is that as long
as magneto continues this this lifestyle
of reforming his actions of trying to
regain the trust of both mutant kind as
well as humanity that the time will come
when the x-men will begin to trust him
as well and so from here we switch to
issue number 201 and with issue number
201 we see the fallout of what happens
when magneto takes over the Xavier
Institute and for the most part most of
the x-men have already left at this
point the original x-men anyway and
while they had initially been saved by
the new x-men from the living Island
what we also saw was that Cyclops was
again the last member left and so to
reference our video on the x-men this is
the point at which the new x-men have
already been established in SCI cloth
is still a part of the team at the same
time cyclops had been with madeline
prior the clone of jean grey for about a
year or so and madeleine prior was
pregnant with their son Nathan summers
and so Cyclops was in this mindset where
he was trying to find a way to balance
being a part of the x-men as well as the
impending fatherhood that was coming
down the road and so what he did is he
started a duel with storm and he told
storm that if she won that he would step
down as the team leader of the x-men and
she would take his place
storm was ultimately successful in being
able to defeat Cyclops and so Cyclops
stepped down which takes us into
x-factor issue number one
now x-factor was initially written by
Bob Layton up until issue number four
and what Bob Layton did here is he made
a few changes he actually reintroduced
Jean Grey and the way that he did this
was actually pretty fantastic one of the
coolest ways to reintroduce a character
what we see is we start off with
x-factor issue number one is that were
with Cyclops and Madeline Pryor in
Anchorage Alaska and Cyclops is trying
to adapt to this life of not being part
of the x-men with Cyclops having been
part of the x-men for almost his entire
tire youth as well as his adult life for
the most part he's still torn between
the ideas of maintaining or fighting on
behalf of the x-men and trying to
maintain the ideas of Charles Xavier but
he also has a son to raise and he has a
wife that's dependent on him and so he's
torn in a lot of different ways and this
is something that manifests itself in
several forms but again for the most
part what Madeline Pryor tells him is
that Jean Grey is dead that he needs to
stop focusing on the past he needs to
stop focusing on the on the x-men he
used to focus on his life here at the
moment at this point we switched to
Warren Worthington the third and Warren
Worthington is with his longtime friend
Kandy southern and as the two of them
are together
Warren gets a phone call from Reed
Richards initially Warren is a
dismissive of the phone call he tries to
blow it off but once he actually answers
the phone and speaks with Reed Richards
he immediately takes off for New York
from here we transitioned to New York as
as Warren Worthington is meeting with
Reed Richards and Warren Worthington of
course uses his wings to fly into the
airport and Reed Richards says this was
a terrible idea and the reason why is
because
body knows that he's a mutant now and
that for the most part because there's
so much anti-mutant hysteria he's most
likely going to invoke the fear in the
ire of almost all the humans within this
airport which of course is something
that we see happen before the two of
them are able to escape back to the
Avengers mansion from this point we
learn the other half of the conversation
that Warren Worthington was having with
Reed Richards and what Reed Richards
tells us is that Jean Grey is alive that
Jean Grey was actually not killed
although we don't know the circumstances
yet as to how it was that she's alive in
the first place because again after the
events of the Dark Phoenix saga we were
left to believe that that Jean Grey had
been killed from here we switched to the
Waldorf Astoria Hotel as Cyclops is
arriving to meet with Warren Worthington
and what Warren Worthington has done is
he has hired police to effectively block
off the entire floor to keep anybody
from getting in there and when Scott
Summers arrives initially the police try
to keep him from accessing it until one
of them speaks up and says the Cyclops
is supposed to be here at which time
they of course allow him through to meet
with Warren and at this point it seems
as the warrant and a warrant has already
told us Cyclops what's going on that
Jean Grey is here and so it's Cyclops is
meeting with Jean Grey he's astounded to
see that she is actually alive he
thought that for the most part maybe was
some kind of a ruse or that perhaps
there was something else going on here
and so for him this is a very real
situation a very stark situation because
again the feelings of Cyclops had for
Jean Grey the love that he had for her
was something that never went away
and the fact that Madeleine Pryor was a
clone of Jean Grey and looked identical
to her is something that made the
situation even more intense for him from
here we see the two of them reuniting
and we of course see that again Scott
Summers is trying to get used to what it
is it's going on here and Warren
Worthington joins the the two of them
and what Warren does is he tells us what
it is it had taken place he tells us how
it is a Jean Grey was actually alive and
what he tells us is that during the
Phoenix saga when Jean Grey had
supposedly become the Phoenix a Jean
Grey was in fact never the Phoenix that
she had never taken on the form of the
Phoenix that what had happened was when
the the shuttle that they were using had
crashed
into the bottom of Jamaica Bay that Jean
Grey had been placed in a stasis pod and
that the Phoenix had taken on her
physical form and Warren tells us that
he knows this because at some point
along the line the Avengers had received
a call about some kind of an object that
was radiating energy from the bottom of
Jamaica Bay and when they arrived there
they found the stasis pod that Jean Grey
was being housed in and so when they
opened it up they actually found Jean
Grey inside and so from here we see that
for the most part Jean Grey is trying to
talk about her experiences trying to
figure out what it is this been going on
and what she tells us is two things the
first is that her telepathic powers are
almost non-existent and that her
telekinetic powers have been enhanced
several times over but what she also
does is she asks them about what it is
this going on with the x-men the things
appear to have been changed that Cyclops
and Angel and and others are no longer
part of the x-men and the x-men or a new
team as well as the fact that Charles
Xavier doesn't appear to be here anymore
and so what she asks them is what role
they're playing with regards to being
superheroes Warren Worthington says that
he's not a superhero anymore that he
doesn't do that kind of thing anymore
and Cyclops says the same thing and it's
at this point the Jean Grey gets really
really angry and the reason why is
because she feels as though they're
abandoning the idea of Charles Xavier is
dream a peaceful coexistence between
humans and mutants and so she
immediately takes off for trying to
figure out what it is she wants to do
trying to figure out I don't know maybe
what kind of stance she should take if
she should take any kind of a stance at
this point she's joined by Warren
Worthington as he's been following her
and trying to keep tabs on her and what
he tells her is that she's right that it
is their responsibility as individuals
with superpowers to use those
superpowers for the betterment of not
just mutant kind but to also ensure that
some measure of people peaceful
coexistence is maintained if not
enhanced by the relationship between
humans and mutants and so what we do is
we switch to the various x-men are
various former original x-men as we see
them going about their day to day lives
beast is attempting to attain a position
with the Harvard Medical School but the
Dean of Medicine turns them down due to
the fact that the faculty are not very
happy with a new
working with the working in their
department from here we switch to Bobby
Drake and Bobby Drake is working with
some kind of an accounting firm and he
gets a call from someone on behalf of
Warren Worthington and we don't again
don't necessarily know what the
conversation is but whatever this
conversation is indicates that Warren
Worthington wants the company of Bobby
Drake for presumably some kind of
conversation and Bobby Drake of course
immediately agrees and takes off to meet
with everybody at this point we pick up
about six hours later on the Manhattan
Lower East Side and some building that
is apparently owned by Warren
Worthington and we see that all the
original x-men have for the most part
gathered back together and after
everybody I guess beasts and and and
Bobby Drake and others are surprised to
see that Jean Grey is alive they of
course meet and they talk and catch up
and so on until they're actually called
into a room with with Warren Worthington
and what Warren Worthington tells us is
that he has brought along his his
college roommate Cameron Hodge and
Cameron Hodge has vast experience in NPR
in marketing and he's going to basically
market the team in such a way to where
they'll be receptive by humanity and
initially no one really knows how this
is going to happen people know for the
most part believe this is actually going
to take place and the x-men or the
original x-men are a little less
skeptical here but what Cameron Hodge
tells them is that the anti-mutant
hysteria is at an all-time high and so
the best way for them to function is to
take that mutant hysteria and to turn it
on itself and so what he says is that
they are basically going to operate as a
group of people who are masquerading as
mutant hunters and now they're going to
operate under the name of x-factor the
reason being because mutants have an X
factor in their genetic makeup which is
the reason why they have powers in the
first place and so what he shows them is
this 30-second ad that would be it's
actually on TV already whereby people
can call a 1-800 number that would lead
directly to the phone line and the at
the headquarters of X Factor to report
any kind of suspicious mutant activity
and what X Factor will do is they will
arrive on the scene they'll masquerade
is so they're trying to capture the
mutants and then they'll take them for
safekeeping and so what this is
basically doing is allowing them to
continue the idea of
screaming mutants from any kind of
oppression at the hands of humans in the
same way that the Xavier Institute would
do with younger mutants but what it does
is it allows them to educate mutants in
terms of the appropriate the proper use
of their powers for the greater good as
well as make sure that anti-mutant
hysteria stays quelled and this for the
most part is how x-factor functions for
the next 70 some-odd issues because of
course the original x-men team lead with
issue number 70 and for the most part
over the course of these comics were
introduced to a litany of new characters
a litany of new situations and all kinds
of different stories and this is what
made x-factor so popular with the
x-factor comics by issue number 5 Louise
Simonson had taken over and Louise
Simonson had actually spearheaded the
idea of a crossover between all the
x-men and x-factor related titles the
Generation X titles on the new mutants
x-man and x-factor this was all her idea
and so with x-factor issue number 13 we
saw that Cyclops who had previously
abandoned Madeline Pryor and Nathan
Sommers at the end of x-factor issue
number one began this quest to try to
find out what it was that it happened to
Madelyn Pryor and to his son with
x-factor issue number 15 we saw that
angel lost his wings now later on is
revealed to us this was due to the
actions of Cameron Hodge and that
Cameron Hodge had actually been working
against one Worthington for quite some
time and with issue number 18 we see
that apocalypse approaches Warren
Worthington with the opportunity to
replace his wings to restore his ability
of flight and this is when we see the
the Horsemen of Apocalypse really begin
to take a main stage in Marvel Comics
with issue number 19 we get the first
appearance of the four horsemen albeit
without the fourth one without death
with issue number 24 the four horsemen
return but it's with the the company of
Warren Worthington as arc angel or the
horseman death with issue number 37 we
saw the return of Madeline Pryor during
the inferno tie-ins for x-factor and
this of course was a story where by
Madeline Pryor had effectively become
the Goblin Queen and she had opened a
portal between a demon dimension and the
earth-616 dimension in retribution for
what it was that had happened with
Scotts
with x-factor issue number 70 the
original x-men team had in effect left
they had disbanded and they had gone
back to the to the x-men proper and this
is where we saw the x-factor comics
begin to switch by issue number 64
Louise Simonson had already left the ax
factor comics and so in 1991 with
x-factor issue number 71 the lineup
changed and the lineup now consisted of
strong guy Jimmy madrix Wolfsbane
Polaris and Quicksilver now over the
course of the publication after issue
number 71 going into the 200s and Beyond
we saw that x-factor for the most part
their lineup began to change yet again
over several times of course we would
see people like Ford to join up with the
with the x-factor team and by the time
the house of M story had come around the
x-factor team had moved away from being
this team masquerading as mutant hunters
to be more or less an investigative team
a team that would investigate all
different kinds of scenarios and they
would be based out of mutant town now
what it is that Marvel chooses to do
with the x-factor team going into the
future is something we don't really know
we're not really sure if Marvel is even
going to have anything to do with
x-factor or if it's if it's possible
that the x-factor team is simply run its
course and there's no real interest and
x-factor anymore but again this is all
up for speculation this is all up for
the possibility that Marvel may
reinstate the team in 2015 during their
their massive summer event with that
being said we're going to go ahead and
bring this video to and and I hope you
guys enjoyed it if you did let me know
and I will catch you guys later peace
you